est ce que vous connaissez cette marque
de voiture c'est vinh faste alors je
connaissais absolument pas il y en a
plein ocs a dès l'instant qu'ils ont qui
est soudainement incroyable lancer une
marque qui vient de jeu monsieur zhu zhu
pets je ne sais pas en tout cas j'aime
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup le design ça
super stylé super beau voir si ça
arrivera un jour sans le marché français
peut-être peut-être pas en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que des marques
automobiles qu'on ne soupçonne pas
encore la vieille en a des tonnes et
celle là je dois reconnaître que
franchement elle est super sympa je
pense lui que moi en commentaire